أه ماري ، أرجو أن تعلم أن خواطرنا
وصلواتنا مع أهل
تركيا وسوريا في هذا الوقت أريد أن
أسأل أولاً وقبل كل شيء كيف حالك وكيف حال
أسرتك في هذا الوقت الصعب للغاية ،
شكرًا لك نعم إنه كما قلت إنه
وقت صعب حقًا أنا بخير ،
وعائلتي جيدة لأنهم
يعيشون في إسطنبول ، لكن بطريقة أخرى
نحن مستعدون حقًا لما
يحدث في شمال تركيا ،
لذا نعم فقط أقول مثل هذا يوم السبت
حزينًا جدًا حقًا نحن  علمنا
بخبر لاعب
كرة القدم الغاني الدولي كريستيان أتسو
الذي تم العثور على جثته تحت الأنقاض
كيف تشيد به وبحياته
نعم إنه أمر محزن حقًا
لأنني رأيت كل ذلك اليوم من
المقابلة و  أعجبتني قلت إنه أمر
محزن حقًا لأنه لعب بالفعل قبل
14 أو 15 يومًا من مباراته الأخيرة
ونقاطه أيضًا في هذه المباراة ولكن آه على الهواء ،
أنا حزين حقًا لا أعرف أنني
لا أعرف ما الذي أريده  أستطيع أن أقول إنك تعلم
لأنني أشعر حقًا بأنني مستعد حقًا
لعائلته ، ولا يمكنني
قول المزيد لأنني حزين حقًا وفي
أوقات كهذه رأينا
مجتمع دوري كرة القدم العالمي يجتمع معًا
كواحد اليوم في اللغة الإنجليزية
الدوري الإنجليزي الممتاز تحية لكريستيان
أتسو
وإيماءاته القوية حقًا والتي تتحدث كثيرًا عنه
كشخص ولاعب أيضًا ، نعم ، نعم ،
أرى أيضًا أن بعض
الأندية الأساسية فعلت بعضها مثل تشيلسي مثل نيك
جاستن لأنه لعب هذا  هذه
الأندية
كما أقول هي لحظة صعبة حقًا
ولا أعرف ما يمكنني قوله
وأتمنى أو لعائلته لأصدقائه
إنها لحظة صعبة حقًا